>>> HEY.MEABTHIN
BIOT WHAT THUMRR
WHR  F
SHRR
YLA S.LLION, THAT'THE
ON AG
4.35 MILLION, THAT THE NUMBER I'
RECORD-SHATTERG
SWIFTS GLOB YR.T'S THE NUMBER
$200 MILLION IR
MERCH HAS BEEN SOLD SOAR.
COKNOWPUR  SLYT SIZEMAININX D 4.
NEO.
TAORR SOAL MWH TOUR,OW MUCH MER
WIHE S M EN ILL BE, A, TT E  A,
GETING
AT IS MIO ETIN
THE  OINARALS SE
ONAL VULTEO TAYLOR INT
LOT ANDAPHIC TH THE TEA, EMAL
G D PANA. TRULY TF A , E THDASP
MEDIA FOLLOWING,
ON TIKTOL THN D
TOOUP.
ACCORDING TO POLLINGY SRSS,
E MAJORITY ALTS ENTIFI63% OF WO.
HER FANS EVENLVID
49.NG INDD OPDEPENDHER FANS AG
% REPORTED HOUSEHOLDNCDER $50,00
ED MEDIAE SHOULD REGISTO
VOTE NEARLY 00RICANS 29, DIDO I.
.EHA G THAN 10F WHOM
WHHEN PTEMBER SHED
THS T ABAGING
ROVELETA, AND THAT'S WKEP  IN AN
T S ARERED INTO E
ROONGIM OOUIT WASOR FS  THE MIL
WHAT MIGHT BE THE VALU ORWIFT EO
HERE.TS?HAWESTERN UNER SCHOOL OU
THE WATHAT EORSEMENTTE TS,
CIS,
TH
DO THEY?
>>T L DEPES
ENDORSEMT.
SEE SO MTIG FOR THEM.HEY
WE LOOKED AT OPRAH'S
ENDORSENOF PDURING THE 2008 PRI
FOUND ITAD
THE SHARHE ABLE ASE TO W
THE 2008E DENT.
A , YLOR SWIU THINK TH'SE
APPLE TOPPLES  GOING
TO GETRMS OFHAN
COISONS YOU TALK
BEFEYVE
OPRAIN ONLY ONE
OF PEO TIMES
THE YEAR,  AND CENTURYSH TWO
ATHE HEER POPULARITY
SHE LOOK AE TO BUY PRODUCTBYM.
ECTI.LD VE A LGE IN THIS
>>'M TPUT HERESE I
WANT THE S
I HAVE ACTUALLY READ
OPRAH'SDORSEMENDEA MILLIOS K O.
W DIYOU DO IT?
MAGAZINE.
ED REGIO
E POPULARITYR MAGAZINETOS PARTET
IS
RAL TIA
PRIMAR
NTON WE IDENT OBAN
VERY SIMIL CTEIN
OF THEIROLICIES.
HERE THEY'RE VER
THESIDENT BIDEN AND RMPRESIDENT.
YOUR POINTS ON DATA, IE OUT
OD NEVER BEENTICALLY ACTIVE LIB
SIMP ENDSEME
OTT ONHEN
TRAIL, APPEANGN SWINATN YOU GEO
STES A YOU HA ENT BEN
E N,PLOW UP AND THEY'RE NOT SHOI
THAT LEVELNT FRO
TO SHOW UP TO SEE
SEEAYLOR  TURN
OU THES E THEM.
VWERFUL BUTNEYOND SAYG, HE FOR ,
SAW OPRAH DO THROUOUT THE 2008
INREST ME, ALLL
TETH HAD A DCHIEFSLD ENDURE.RD
HEA WAY THATCAMPAIWOO VEENCE.
>>EA
TO
H  AND THEY'RE AUALLY  LISTEN, T
OUR FAVERY WHAT SHE HAS TO CHING
BACT AND THE FACT THASTEN TO WH
>> QUIINAL.
U ARE OFTRYOARE INELLOL E ISSUIS
>> THEMICHAEL RD
BU RIGHTEVEP
MOVE FOR HER.SA I AVENL
S ISSUE.
THAT SAID, SHE IS ATHE WANTED  I
G SI.HT..ON IMOO
THS XPIOTHAT.
IT IS SOMETHING YOD AINLTE
EAH, THANK YOU.
OW WHAINK.
T WEBSITE A
NEOUE SISH.COMOW WHERE THIN TOD.
RACE? NBE
40 VES
DETERMINED, SWUNG THE LAST COUL
ROM UENCE?
WORL YouTube,
HAVE?SWIFT MAKES THN IMPACTFUG
00HET E IN THREE STATES ULF ECTN